what's up everybody its Derek from new
media rock stars we're on the gifts and
tour bus and we're about to have
ourselves a little fun when we go ahead
and play a recap from the last day of
playlist live hashtag playlist Ross our
hashtag party
let us live suddenly we're in the green
justice mouse how are you yeah yeah
Celeste
so there you
No
if there is a YouTube Mount Rushmore
where the four heads up y'all Wow 12 and
then probably just
through with Madeline on the last and
playlist Madeline Madeline Madeline
don't spit up guys
Oh
these guys playlist was great new day
rocks oh he's had a great time thanks to
everybody that like let us shoot videos
with you we've got a lot of amazing
people is a good time we did a lot of
fun stuff and once you go ahead and
subscribe to new media rocks us right
now check us out new media resource com
hey this is Alan fan editor-in-chief of
new media rap stars com we are here at
playlist live 2014 it was amazing thank
you to all the fans that came out and
thank you to all the creators that we
talked to everybody was amazing was
awesome we loved it and remember to
check us out on youtube.com slash new
media rock stars and of course check us
out on new video rockstars com we have
amazing stuff coming out I said amazing
like 15 times but it's amazing amazing
amazing so check us out alright peace I